Queridos amigos, parece que nacimos ayer,
pero lo cierto es que VisualPolitik lleva
ya más de 7 años aquí en esta plataforma, en
YouTube. Durante este tiempo hemos publicado
más de 870 vídeos - ¡Qué locura! -También hemos
visto nacer a Megaprojekts, a VisualEconomik,
y varias newsletter como las claves
de la Semana de Patreon o NotNews.
Por supuesto, todo esto ha sido posible gracias
a todos vosotros. A los más de 3 millones de
suscriptores que formáis parte de esta comunidad y
que nos acompañáis día tras día, mes tras mes, año
tras año. Eso es algo que, podéis creerme, todos
los miembros de este equipo tenemos muy claro.
Pues bien, hoy con este vídeo estrenamos una
colaboración que nos hace muchísima ilusión.
Este es el primer vídeo que en VisualPolitik
hemos preparado con nuestros amigos de Harvard
International Review. En la descripción os dejamos
unos cuantos enlaces para que les conozcáis mejor.
Esperamos que el resultado os
guste tanto como a nosotros.
En 2018, Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
AMLO, fue elegido presidente de México.
Y no solo eso. Este antiguo
alcalde de la capital del país,
que ya se había postulado a la presidencia en
2006 y 2012, no soló gano las presidenciales,
sino que, además, por primera
vez desde 1988, el partido del
presidente también logró la mayoría en
el Senado y en la Cámara de Diputados.
De esta forma, los Estados Unidos
Mexicanos quedaron casi por completo
bajo el control de AMLO y de su partido,
el Movimiento Regeneración Nacional.
La victoria de AMLO, que se
presentó como el hombre del pueblo,
acabó con el binomio político que dominó
la política mexicana durante casi 90 años.
Entre 1929 y el año 2000, el gobierno
mexicano estuvo en manos del Partido
Revolucionario Institucional, el PRI. En
el 2000 Vicente Fox del Partido de Acción
Nacional consiguió romper ese monopolio. A él
le siguió Felipe Calderón, otro político del
mismo partido. Y solo en 2012 el PRI recuperó
el gobierno de la mano de Enrique Peña Nieto.7
Sin embargo, no supuso un gran cambio,
no al menos no un cambio tan pronunciado
como la victoria de AMLO y MORENA en 2018.
Porque lo cierto es que el actual
presidente mexicano llegó al poder
esencialmente con 3 grandes promesas:
Primero, y por encima de todo, ser el
presidente del pueblo. El presidente que
pondría a los pobres primero y acabaría de
una vez por todas con la corrupción de las
grandes élites. Hablamos de tipos como,
por ejemplo, el exgobernador de Veracruz,
Javier Duarte, que supuestamente
robó casi 3 mil millones de dólares.
Segundo atajar la pobreza y tercero enfrentar
la enorme violencia que padecía el país
Tras llegar al poder, AMLO suspendió la
construcción del nuevo aeropuerto de Ciudad de
México, creó una nueva Guardia Nacional, suspendió
la concesión de nuevas licencias petroleras y las
subastas de energías renovables y sobre todo puso
en marcha un enorme paquete de política social:
Por ejemplo, ha subido el salario mínimo,
ha incrementado los subsidios al gas,
la gasolina y la electricidad y
ha canalizado miles de millones
en transferencias directas a
más de 10 millones de mexicanos.
“Durante los gobiernos neoliberales no se atendió
a la gente humilde. Ahora se atiende a todos,
pero se da preferencia a los
pobres y a los indígenas”.
De esta forma, pese a una economía renqueante,
a que la antaño joya de la corona del estado
mexicano, la petrolera PEMEX está contra las
cuerdas y a que la violencia sigue descontrolada,
lo cierto es que AMLO ha mantenido
altísimos índices de aprobación.
Prácticamente, poder decir que López
Obrador es uno de los líderes más
populares de todo el planeta. Hablamos de tasas
de aprobación de entre el 60% y el 70%. Fijaos.
Claro que en este vídeo nos queremos centrar
en uno de grandes proyectos de este presidente,
una gran inversión con la que pretende revitalizar
una de las regiones más pobre del país.
Estamos hablando, por supuesto, del Tren Maya,
una faraónica obra que costará
cerca de 20.000 millones de dólares,
que atravesará la selva y que nace ni más ni
menos que con la promesa de transformar México.
Atentos.
(CRUZANDO LA SELVA)
“Juntos, estamos haciendo
historia. ¡Qué viva el Tren Maya!"
Es el diamante político de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
el proyecto emblemático que dará forma
a su legado. Una gran obra con la que el
presidente aspira a resucitar económicamente
a una de las regiones más pobres del país.
Esta obra es tan importante para el presidente
mexicano que López Obrador en 2021 llegó a
declararla asunto de seguridad nacional. Lo
hizo para poder reanudar las obras cuando un
tribunal las suspendió por posible violación
de la legislación de impacto ambiental.
Y luego, cuando este decreto fue declarado
inconstitucional, AMLO volvió a publicar
otro decreto revisado en el que insistía
exactamente con lo mismo: el tren maya es
una infraestructura que afecta a la seguridad
nacional y al interés público. Una obra cuya
dirección y supervisión por afectar a la seguridad
nacional recae en las propias fuerzas armadas.
N1 (18 de mayo de 2023: AMLO emite
nuevo decreto para que obras de
infraestructura sean consideradas como
de seguridad nacional. El Economista)
C1 ("Estamos recurriendo a un
procedimiento establecido por
la ley, que es declarar este trabajo de
seguridad nacional, por muchas razones:
porque un gobierno extranjero
(EE. UU.) está interfiriendo,
porque se está perdiendo dinero del presupuesto,
porque es un trabajo prioritario, porque se están
aplicando tácticas de retraso y porque no hay
justicia rápida". Andrés Manuel López Obrador)
Queridos amigos, amigas, con una
longitud de 1.525 kilómetros,
el Tren Maya conectará los estados
de Quintana Roo, Chiapas, Tabasco,
Campeche y Yucatán. Una de las regiones
turísticas más importantes del país.
Esta es con mucho la línea
ferroviaria más ambiciosa
que se ha construido en México en décadas.
Conectará las principales ciudades y regiones
turísticas de la península de Yucatán,
desde las playas de arena blanca Cancún
hasta los restos arqueológicos de Tulum.
Gracias a ello, el gobierno espera que este
tren incremente los ingresos por turismo en
un 20% y que contribuya a crear más de un 1
millón de puestos de trabajo. De esta forma
se ayudaría a reducir la pobreza en la península
de Yucatán. Una región dónde se encuentran algunos
de los estados más pobres de todo México. Por
ejemplo, en estados como Chiapas o Tabasco,
más del 50% de la población vive en
la pobreza o en la extrema pobreza.
Pero…Quizás el mayor problema es que su coste
se ha disparado. La estimación inicial era
de unos 6.500 millones de dólares, luego
se anunció que superaría ligeramente los
11 mil millones. Y ahora, cuando todavía
quedan muchos meses para que terminen las
obras, ya nos hablan de 20.000 millones. Es
posible que la cifra final sea aún más alta.
“El proyecto de tren maya de México costará
hasta 20 mil millones de dólares, un 70 %
por encima del presupuesto. Bloomberg)
El caso queridos amigos es que no
solo hablamos del legado de AMLO,
también de uno de los proyectos
más controvertidos de México. Y,
¿sabéis qué? Justo aquí llegamos
al momento clave de este vídeo:
¿Qué supondrá realmente el Tren Maya? ¿Cuáles
son los principales argumentos a favor y en
contra de esta enorme infraestructura?
¿Realmente tiene sentido? ¿Cómo es
posible que un tren, un simple tren, se
haya convertido en algo tan polémico?
Queridos amigos, amigas, vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas. Vamos a ver cuáles
son las luces, las sombras, las amenazas y
las oportunidades del gran sueño de AMLO.
T2 (LUCES Y SOMBRAS)
Un tren de México para México. Este es el
objetivo del gobierno y por eso tanto la línea
como los 42 trenes que lo harán funcionar han
sido diseñados y construidos en el propio país.
“Estamos construyendo el Tren Maya, 1550
Km, y los trenes se están haciendo aquí,
en Ciudad Sahagún, Hidalgo, para dar trabajo
a los mexicanos”. Andrés Manuel López Obrador
Eso sí, los ha construido la empresa
francesa Alstom. [Así que, no sé,
casi que mejor decimos que es un tren casi
de México para México, ¿no os parece?]
Pero, por supuesto, sea como sea, eso
no es más que una pequeña curiosidad.
Lo importante es que el gobierno
espera que este tren sea utilizado
por más de 8.000 viajeros diarios, más de
3 millones de pasajeros cada año. Vale,
no es una cifra muy alta, pero esta línea
de ferrocarril no solo transportará viajeros
sino también mercancías. Y quizás
este es una de las grandes claves.
De hecho, si repasamos el proyecto y los
argumentos de quienes lo han impulsado,
nos podemos encontrar con 3 grandes
claves, los 3 grandes argumentos,
los 3 grandes cambios que se espera
que produzca este nuevo tren.
En primer lugar, el turismo es muy importante
para México y se espera que lo sea mucho más en
los próximos años. Tanto en lo que respecta al
turismo nacional como internacional. Pues bien,
con la llegada de este nuevo ferrocarril, el
gobierno espera que los estados del sureste
tengan una oferta turística mucho
más atractiva y que esto impulse la
economía y ayude a crear con el tiempo
cientos de miles de puestos de trabajo.
Por así decirlo, que este tren ponga en marcha
algo así como la fiebre del oro del ferrocarril
mexicano. De hecho, las estimaciones del gobierno
hablan ni más ni menos que de 1 millón de empleos.
Pero eso no es todo. En segundo
lugar, AMLO defiende que esta obra es,
esencialmente, una reparación histórica.
Y es que veréis, tradicionalmente la
mayor parte de la riqueza de México se
ha concentrado sobre todo en la capital
y en los estados del norte del país,
que lógicamente son los más
cercanos a Estados Unidos. Eso
ha hecho que las infraestructuras del
sur estén habitualmente infradotadas.
Bajo este prisma, el Tren Maya tendría la misión
de corregir esa carencia histórica y permitir que
en esta región donde viven más de 13 millones de
personas surjan muchos más negocios y empresas.
C2 ("Este es un acto de justicia,
porque esta región ha sido la más
abandonada". Andrés Manuel López Obrador)
Lo que nos lleva directamente al tercer argumento
que apoya este proyecto: las mercancías.
Tren de carga, ¡esto es muy importante! Porque
ahora se mueve mucha mercancía por camiones y
cuesta mucho el transporte de carga. Cuesta
más barato el transporte de carga por tren.
El Tren Maya se ha vendido como una gran apuesta
turística, pero en realidad es, ante todo,
un tren de mercancías. Esta es la parte que se
espera pueda darle realmente dinero al proyecto.
Eso sí, cuando hablamos de mercancías
hablamos fundamentalmente de PEMEX,
la gran petrolera pública que supone el
80% de toda la carga que se mueven en la
región. Es decir, que PEMEX y no el turismo
será el principal cliente de este proyecto.
Pero, ¿entonces? ¿Dónde surge la controversia? No
sé, a priori las luces parecen
bastante claras, ¿no os parece?
Impulso al turismo, superación de una
brecha histórica de infraestructuras y
la posibilidad de que algunos de los
estados más pobres de México tengan
ahora una columna vertebral para el
transporte de mercancías, lo que,
por supuesto, podría animar a muchas
empresas a instalarse en la región.
Pues queridos amigos, si hemos visto 3 grandes
luces, también podemos encontrar otras 3 grandes
sombras. 3 grandes críticas que se le hacen
a este faraónico proyecto. ¿Y sabéis qué?
Justo con las mercancías nos
encontramos con la primera:
Y es que veréis, el problema es que la península
del Yucatán está muy poco industrializada y,
además, el Tren Maya no está - al menos por
ahora - conectado con el resto de la red.
Es decir, que básicamente dependerá de un
cliente (PEMEX) y en los trayectos de vuelta,
una vez entregada la mercancía, los vagones y los
contenedores pueden tener que ir prácticamente
vacíos. Lo que elevaría mucho el precio del
transporte y lo haría menos competitivo.
Pero con todo y por mucho, las críticas
más importantes son las dos siguientes.
Por ejemplo, ¿os acordáis de que el coste de las
obras se ha ido ya hasta los 20 mil millones?
Pues ojo, porque el Instituto Mexicano
para la Competitividad señala que esa
cifra es muy probable que también se quede
pequeña. Apuntan a más de 25 mil millones.
Muchos críticos argumentan que todo este enorme
dineral se está gastando para promover el turismo
en una región dónde el turismo ya va viento
en popa. Hablamos de lugares tan conocidos
como Cancún, Puerto del Carmen o la Riviera
Maya. De esta forma hay muchos economistas,
políticos y expertos que apunta
a que invertir todo este dinero
en otro tipo de infraestructuras
más locales, en infraestructuras
digitales o en instalaciones educativas
a la larga podría dar mejores resultados.
Y no solo eso. El estado mexicano cierra cada
año sus cuentas en rojo. En 2022, por ejemplo,
tuvieron un déficit de cerca del 4% del PIB
y se espera que en 2023 cierre con un 3,6%.
Eso quiere decir que el tren se tendrá que
financiar con deuda. ¿Y cuál es el problema?
Qué el estado mexicano está emitiendo su
deuda a 10 años a tipos de entorno al 8%.
Esto quiere decir que si, finalmente, el coste
de la obra fuese de 20 mil millones de dólares,
el estado mexicano, devaluaciones
aparte, podría llegar a tener que
desembolsar cada año más de 1.600 millones
solo en concepto de interés. Y luego, claro,
estarían los costes de explotación. Y todo
junto es lo que explica titulares como este:
N3 (El Tren Maya nunca tendrá ganancias y siempre
necesitará subsidios del gobierno: PAN. InfoBae)
Por supuesto, los partidarios de la obra
confían en que las mercancías lograrán
que el tren sí sea rentable. Y en cualquier
caso apuestan porque la actividad económica
que se genere en la región podría compensar con
mucho cualquier pérdida concreta. Por ejemplo,
hablamos de ese millón de nuevos empleos que
pronostica el gobierno. ¿Será esto posible? Solo
el tiempo podrá dictar sentencia. Por ahora si
algo está claro es que los números son ambiciosos
Sea como sea, todavía nos falta por ver
la última gran crítica. Una crítica que
no tiene nada que ver con el dinero,
sino con algo totalmente distinto:
4 de febrero de 2023: Preocupa que el Tren
Maya de México destruya la selva. AP News
El Tren Maya atraviesa y conecta lugares
increíbles. Hablamos, por ejemplo, de la selva
maya, la segunda más grande de América, tan solo
por detrás del Amazonas y que está habitada por
especie que están en peligro de extinción como los
jaguares o el tapir centroamericano, entre otros.
Pues bien, un tercio de todo el recorrido
pasará por estos bosques tropicales.
Incluso, durante más de 120 kilómetros,
el Tren Maya atravesará la Reserva de
la Biosfera de Calakmul, una de
las áreas naturales protegidas
más grandes de todo México y uno de
los sitios arqueológicos mayas más
importantes. Un lugar que es considerado
como Patrimonio Mundial por la UNESCO.
Por su parte, la población indígena
tampoco parece entusiasmada. Entre
otras cosas quizás, porque más de 2.000
familias han tenido que ser desplazadas.
C3 ("Este proyecto no está planeado para nosotros,
la gente común [...] Es un proyecto turístico que
solo beneficiará a los ricos y a los extranjeros.
Nosotros, que somos los propietarios de la tierra,
solo la veremos pasar, porque no hay
estaciones planificadas para la mayoría
de nuestras comunidades". Carta abierta de
las Comunidades Indígenas del Yucatan en 2018)
Pues bien, queridos, amigos, amigas,
estos son las 3 grandes luces y las 3
grandes sombras de uno de los mayores proyectos de
infraestructuras de las últimas décadas en México.
En cualquier caso, si algo parece claro
no solo es que el Tren Maya ha llegado,
lógicamente, para quedarse, sino
que también tiene la oportunidad
de ser un punto de inflexión para una de las
regiones más pobres de México. Por supuesto,
ya hemos visto que existen algunos inconvenientes.
Mitigar esos problemas tendrá que ser el objetivo
del gobierno mexicano durante los próximos años.
Solo el tiempo nos podrá dar el veredicto final.
Dicho lo cual, la pregunta ahora
es para ti: ¿Qué os parece el Tren
Maya? ¿Qué opinión os genera? Dejarnos
vuestras impresiones en los comentarios.
Esperamos que este primer vídeo entre
VisualPolitik y Harvard International Review
os haya gustado tanto como a nosotros.
Si es así, no olvidéis darle a like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.